okay so you used some rice but the
principle without bitching what you said
today was quite impossible it's not
anything up I agree with what you said
because what you're saying is actually
quite powerful you're you're making an
admission that you should be able to
remove it you should be able to make it
a Christian and that you have made today
which I'm very grateful for which is
that it's conceivable it's possible for
you to believe in parts of the New
Testament and not all of the New
Testament and still be eligible for
salvation that is what you said because
we said what gave us in Asia is what
gave him the right to choose what books
would be in the New Testament you agree
that okay that they became known and so
on but if you don't agree with the
twenty-seven books
it doesn't necessarily fire you from
salvation and from being a Christian
what I'm saying is the question of what
should be acceptable and what should it
be acceptable should be to the good
judgment of people who look into the
scripture and do the historical research
and through rationalization
also this decide that certain things are
impossible and therefore reject aspects
of that Scripture if you allow some
parts of the scripture to be taken out
then it should be to the good discretion
of each individual reader to decide what
those parts would be it's not good
enough to say to someone okay you don't
need to have all 27 books of the New
Testament
you don't need you to believe in this
New Testament but you have to believe in
these parts this is my summary so my
summary is this Muhammad is already
accepted that it is quite proper to
choose your Canon based upon your belief
system which is what he admitted when we
talked about the sheer Sunni honey now
it follows therefore that as Christians
we are also quite improper to do the
same
the salvation
gospel that was taught by the first
apostles was not written down and then
handed out like a tract it was preached
someone can be saved by knowing the good
news about Jesus and believing on it
without ever having a New Testament in
their hand that we believe in and if
someone believes in that gospel in the
letter of James or about the Book of
Revelations their faith is deficient but
not deficient in such a way that would
cause them not to be saved because it is
your faith in Christ his crucifixion and
resurrection that complete work that
saves you not your knowledge of the
Scriptures it is obviously better yes if
you know the Scriptures and I can't take
lectures from Mohammed hijab because
Muhammad hijab is freely admitted but
for 1400 years Muslims have not agreed
about their hadith but Christians have
agreed about the New Testament and the
debate was settled amongst Christians
from 410 onwards so we can finally
notice
the Christians would listen to Mohammed
the Muslims are not polite to listen to
the Christians so genuine thank you let
us continue here the Christian faith is
based upon the gospel it is not based
upon a book the church recognized in the
writings that were circulating amongst
themselves those books that he
recognized as containing a classic
Gospels mostly Finnish yes let me finish
one question let me finish let me finish
by contrast disagree about their hadith
and so it is not an argument to say that
because Christians may disagree about
certain books but therefore the faith is
invalid no no if that argument is
logical
Islam is invalid finally I made a point
that the Quran makes a claim about
history it says that there was an in
deal
given to a man called Issa there is
absolutely no evidence for this claim
whereas the New Testament is continuous
to the reliability it was already in 2
Peter chapter 3 a sense of what
Scripture was when he says
impor would say in scripture that is
hard to understand I talked about the
Gnostic spot in the New Testament that
the community that the covenant
community always had the idea of
covenant and word comes from dr. Krueger
he talked about we're on the same ground
because you can use natural religion yes
I talked about economic cornelius van
til yes and that we have presuppositions
and you look at history from the Islamic
point of view yeah we have to look at
your glasses and critique it that's why
we need to look at the Koran yeah then
we went on to you and Bob talks about
things yeah the main issues that came up
for me was your is geography yeah what I
found very interesting is when you give
the chain of narration when I asked you
further where you get your scientific
principles from you struggled actually
giving us the answer yeah and then you
admitted your scientific principles yeah
so you're reading back into history why
do you always interrupt the flow
uninterrupted yeah but no neither of us
interrupted you because we had some good
manners not to yet you consistently you
gave the chain of narration we asked you
a critical question where did you get
the methodology for your scientific
Hadees then you told us it came with the
methodology methodology all right
back into history objective
yes back into history yes you look after
yourself next week just one question
when you bring me your evidence all
right where is it yes thank you they've
left me yes so today we came to some
very fruitful conclusions he said that
the New Testament because he realized
after we discussed about a tenacious 27
books of the New Testament has anyone
ever asked themselves why is it the fact
that those 27 books are the 27 books why
is it not for example that the Apocrypha
or it's a gospel of st. Thomas or other
books a part of it what determines what
is in the New Testament and what is not
in the New Testament
what is where is the divine authority of
that determination
so today because of the difficulty of
that question he actually admitted that
actually you don't have to believe that
all 27 books of the New Testament in
order to be a Christian and to get it to
be salvation other words you don't
actually have to believe in the whole
Bible to be a Christian you can believe
in parts of the Bible and not all of the
Bible that is the implication I'm afraid
for us obviously as Muslims we say if
God sent down message then has to be
believed in in its entirety
they cannot be a part of it that's
rejected and a part of it which is
accepted the Quran says after took my
noona be barred in kitabi
what a corona be Bob do you believe in
parts of the book and disbelieve in
parts of the book and subhanAllah do you
know he was talking about it's talking
about the Jews and Chris
yes if I taught my noona by Bardell
kitabi what a coruña bebop firmage semaj
sir
Oh Mia Farrow's aleikum income Illya -
hyah - dunya whalemen committee you are
doing it in a scintilla de amalah hooby
- in a Miami loon that will be the
recompense of someone who does that
except for a punishment in this world
and in the day of judgement they'll be
humiliated even further so if God sent
down a manual for people to follow there
are certain expectations that we have as
people are followers of that manual in
order for us to maintains have salvation
one of them is in fact entitlement we
want this manual for salvation this
guidance to humanity to be intact if
it's not intact it's not agreed upon by
those who specialized in its
preservation then surely there's
something wrong with that you can't say
that ok well I believe in the Bible but
you could but actually is conceivable to
not believe in part of it and to believe
in parts of it so you know it's he he
kept acquitting the hadith the weak
hadith with the Bible which is meant to
be the holiest spot holy spirit-inspired
book of God directly from the Jesus from
Jesus the god what we accept that there
are some things in hadith which are not
acceptable by historical standards but
the comparison should be made between
the Quran and Bible not Quran and hadith
especially not Quran and weak hadith and
so therefore when he realized what he
was asking they were asking me the
questions of preservation that every
question they had every single question
I had those an answer every single
question that they had baba never loved
him
that they asked me a question he said
okay give me a chain of narration he
didn't expect me to stumble gave him
with the chain of narration then he said
to me tell me a document which tab which
proves the chain so I told him the name
of the document which proves the chain
he said to me no no it has to be before
this guy I said no problem
I found it
honestly I found this document it's 95
before yes I told him he said no it has
to be has to be a wise it's only oral I
said no no it can't be only although I
had to be also written what's the
evidence of that he said that he said
okay what a simple gesture he said
what's the evidence from the Prophet I
said the Prophet said write it down he
said Bevin said to me show me the
evidence preservation I said he taught
at each table there must be two of each
person for each area so is that not
evidence that's meant to be from so I
said to him please please Bob
please join his name is Johnny everyone
should know his name is John
I said now let's do the same thing for
the Bible you know he said no he said no
we don't have the same standards I said
I thought this was a historical exercise
I thought this was so anyway at the same
point that's why we can stand here as
Muslims to say in tactimon and
preservation our book the Quran 114
chapters are agreed upon by the Sahaba
someone says no even most out he
believed in hundred and twelve not
Farrakhan s saying no no he changed his
mind but they don't know that he changes
mine in the hydrological and he said
that he change his mind
they said no am Kappa believed in this
116 no no no he didn't believe in that I
believe that under 14 we have the
records for that as well yeah yeah so
everyone will all the Sahaba believed in
this and the Quran tells us in Amman
will be female
I meant to be for cutting teto were in
towel offering them I hope you rock if
they believe in what you guys believe in
then they're on the right path who's you
guys it's the Sahaba if the Sahaba
I agree that this is what the Quran is
because these people were around the
Prophet they heard it and there's a
consensus on this then that's an
historical evidence a religious one
that's the illogical one a rational one
a philosophical one and for me a
satisfactory one as well as satisfactory
one as well but when you talk about the
Bible and you can't even provide one
chain of provenance one person what what
one chain of Providence what
yeah no chain and one person who's met
Jesus spoken to Jesus and we don't come
on and now you're telling me you can he
said to me it met he said you can you
don't have to believe in all the books
of the New Testament he said so no I
said okay perfectly I said to him I
that's perfect
he said that's exactly my belief I don't
believe in all the New Testament
I believe in part of the New Testament I
reject another part so now he tells me
no you have to believe in these parts
salvation crucifixion and listen thank
God no no no no you can't tell me now
you have you have an intellectual right
to accept and reject parts of the New
Testament on academic grounds and then
dictate to me where the rejection should
be where the accepting should be and so
on
and even said you don't even need the
New Testament for for for salvation and
then I said to him okay that's that's
perfect because I've got the Quran so
the point is and it's in gentleman the
point is if he if the argument is listen
to this if the argument is that you
don't you need the Gospels the four
Gospels because that could be the
argument so you know you don't need the
27 books is just the four Gospels then
the argument he made is actually self
refuting because he said the first
people who sees words go back on him
this is the first people the first
people to ever believe in Jesus was
there a New Testament was four books so
no he said no so wait a minute you can
believe in Jesus you can believe in
Jesus's message it's conceivable not to
believe in the four Gospels and still be
a Christian and be saved
that's our position that's our position
that's our position
and moreover what I'll say to you is
this in the in the book of Corinthians
2nd Corinthians
yes verse number 18 can we get out
somewhere can we let's see
let's see I wanna see it refers to a
sink in a book he makes an argument from
silence and he doesn't even know what
that meant when I told them an argument
from silence is that he said that this
knew this gospel this gospel that you're
referring to that a singular gospel of
Jesus it's nowhere in history to be
found I said that just because you don't
find something in history it doesn't
mean it doesn't exist this argument from
silence and I gave him the example of
the lack of my comedy text 1945 to prove
my point but look at this in the second
book of second Corinthians verse number
18 and we have sent with him the brother
who whose praise is in that gospel
throughout all of the churches the
Gospels not the Gospels the idea is even
in the Anthony in the oldest text the
idea of a gospel a singular gospel was
being referred to so there is evidence
in the in the books that they believe in
obviously that's Paul so in summary
that's why Christianity now people are
living it and Islam it makes sense from
all perspectives not just from a
Trinitarian perspective but from a
preservation perspective it makes sense
from a rational perspective yes guys I
mean if you're a Christian and you're
watching this yes one question yes
you know the Muslim are we allowed to do
argument or do Dawa to a non-muslim
without having of knowledge of Islam no
you have to have some knowledge so I
have seen a lot of Muslim brothers that
the astac after Wilson yes and they
should not come here I was telling them
I was shouting to the my mouth yeah dude
our so my message to the Christians is
guys look within whether you look from a
preservation perspective a textual
perspective a rational perspective or
even an intuitive perspective the answer
is always going to be one that you
believe in one God you cannot bring
yourself to believe in three and one and
one and three you don't accept your
story of the entire New Testament it
makes perfect sense it made perfect
sense for there to have been a renewal
of the faith through another prophet one
that we believe it is predicted in the
New Testament and the Old Testament who
came in the form of Muhammad in the
Arabian Peninsula seven centuries I saw
after pray before